hallo ihr Lieben hier ist wieder ein
neuer ferienrey Upload für euch während
wir und vielleicht auch ihr in der
Sommerpause seid kommen heute zwei
spannende Fälle die die Justiz an ihre
Grenzen gebracht haben und in beiden
Fällen von heute waren es Frauen die in
die Mühlen der Rechtsprechung gerieten
und bei denen bis heute unklar ist wie
schwer ihre Schuld wirklich wiegt wir
starten mit Marianne Wachmann
[Musik]
moin und ich bin Natalie Strauß in den
80ern wird zum ersten Mal in der
deutschen Geschichte ein Fall von
Selbstjustiz auf einer langzeiten Bühne
verhandelt ganz Deutschland fiebert mit
als Marianne Bachmeier 1983 ihr Urteil
erwartet die 33-Jährige hat drei Jahre
zuvor den Mord an ihrer siebenjährigen
Tochter Anna gerecht im Gerichtssaal hat
sie den Mörder ihrer Tochter erschossen
man ist hin und hergerissen zwischen dem
Mitgefühl der trauernden Mutter und
ihrer Straftat wir tauchen ein ins Leben
der Marianne Bachmeier und keiner kann
uns besser in die Welt des True Crime
entführen als du lieber Marco vielen
lieben Dank und hallo Natalie und danke
auch an alle unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer
die uns auch heute wieder wohlgesonnen
sind und dem nächsten spannenden
Marianne Bachmeier spaltet die Nation
die einen feiern sie nach ihrer Tat wie
eine Heldin und Fühlen Empathie für die
trauernde Mutter andere verurteilen sie
schwer für die Straftat und bezweifeln
das Marianne eine gute Mutter gewesen
sei so oder so erlebt die Frau eine Form
der Anerkennung die sie so bisher nie
erfahren hat
ihr leiblicher Vater ist Alkoholiker und
verlässt die Familie als Marianne 3
Jahre alt ist ihr Stiefvater ist leider
in keinster Weise eine bessere Wahl
ihrer Mutter der Mann verprügelt
Marianne immer wieder verbietet ihr
später aufs Gymnasium zu gehen und als
sie mit 16 Jahren zum ersten Mal
schwanger wird steckt er sie ins Heim
das Kind gibt sie zur Adoption frei
oh mann die junge Frau hat kein Zuhause
und keine Ausbildung ihr fehlt jeglicher
halt auf die erste früher
Schwangerschaft vor die nächste mit 18
bekommen Sie Ihr nächstes Kind auch
dieses gibt es Adoption frei das sind
die teils aus ihrem Privatleben die als
sie später in der Öffentlichkeit bekannt
werden ihr Ansehen als gute Mutter für
viele deutlich schmälern sollen mit 22
Jahren lernt Marina dann Christian Berg
heute kennen ein Jahr später kommt die
gemeinsame Tochter Anna zur Welt die
kleine Familie zieht in Lübeck zusammen
und zum ersten Mal erfährt Marianne das
Gefühl von echter Geborgenheit und Liebe
aber Mirko wie wir alle wissen ist das
leider nur ein kurzer Glücksmoment ne
tja denn da ist sie nun die junge
Familie aber von Luft und Liebe allein
kann man nicht leben
Marianne Bachmeier wird Kneipenwirtin
und arbeitet in ihrem Lokal tipasa oft
bis spät in die Nacht hinein nicht
selten kommt es daher wohl vor dass sie
morgens nur schwer aus dem Bett kommt so
auch am 5 mai 1980 dem Tag der ihr
ganzes Leben auf den Kopf stellen wird
es ist spät geworden nach ihrer Schicht
in der Kneipe ist die 30-Jährige mitten
in der Nacht ins Bett gefallen als sie
am nächsten Morgen aufwacht hat er
Unterricht ihrer 7 Jahre alten Tochter
längst begonnen jetzt ist es sowieso zu
spät Marianne erlaubt Anna den Schultag
zu schwänzen und zum Spielen rauszugehen
vielleicht hat sich die müde Mutter noch
einmal hingelegt und vertraut darauf
dass ihre Tochter in die Nachbarschaft
zu einer Freundin geht
sie hat sich Marianne soll ihre kleine
Anna nicht mehr lebendig Wiedersehen oh
Gott oh Gott da geht bei mir direkt das
Kopfkino los ja was ist wenn Marianne
nicht verschlafen hätte was wenn Sie
Anna doch in die Schule geschickt hätte
was wenn sie mit ihr gespielt hätte und
Anna nie aus dem Haus gegangen wäre was
wäre wenn ja diese Fragen müssen
Marianne danach unglaublich verfolgt und
gequält haben wie grausam müssen diese
Schuldgefühle dieser jungen Mutter bloß
gewesen sein die siebenjährige anna ist
im 35-Jährigen Fleischer Klaus Grabowski
in die Hände gefallen
der Mann soll sie bei sich zu Hause
mehrere Stunden festgehalten und
schließlich mit einer Strumpfhose
erdrosselt haben
laut Staatsanwaltschaft hat er die
gefesselte Leiche des Mädchens in einen
Karton gepackt und am Ufer eines Kanals
in einer Mulde abgelegt
später soll er die Leiche in ein Loch
gelegt und mit Erde bedeckt haben er hat
die Tat später am Tag seiner Freundin
gebeichtet die daraufhin zur Polizei
geht noch am selben Abend wird Klaus
Grabowski in einer Gaststätte
festgenommen bei der Vernehmung steht
der Mann die Tötung streitet aber
sexuellen Missbrauch ab Klaus Grabowski
ist für die Polizei kein Unbekannter er
ist bereits wegen sexuellen Missbrauch
von Kindern vor bestraft und saß wegen
pädophiler Neigungen an einem
psychiatrischen Krankenhaus das dürfte
er nur verlassen weil er sich freiwillig
einer Kastration unterzogen hat
Mirko ich hatte ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
auf dem Schirm dass das tatsächlich
durchgeführt wird oder wurde und
anscheinend strafmildern ist zudem hat
es ja nicht mal geholfen nein Natalie
das hat es ganz offensichtlich nicht
bzw hätten seine Triebe dadurch
vielleicht unterdrückt werden können
wäre später nicht eine Hormonbehandlung
beim durchgeführt worden die hat dazu
geführt dass sein sexuelles Empfinden
wieder gesteigert wurde auch hier steht
wieder der Satz was wäre wenn über allem
und gibt uns natürlich keine klare
Antwort
die kleine Anna machen diese
Überlegungen nicht wieder lebendig ihre
Eltern Marianne und Christian reichen
erfolglos eine Strafanzeige gegen den
Urologen ein der die Hormonbehandlung
bei Grabowski durchgeführt und somit
ihrer Meinung nach dessen Gefährlichkeit
wiederhergestellt hat nach dem Tod des
kleinen Mädchens werden die Eltern nicht
nur in tiefe Trauer sondern großen Frust
und Fassungslosigkeit gestürzt es
beginnt mit dem vorbestraften
Sexualstraftäter der in ihrer
unmittelbaren Nähe lebt und ihre Tochter
zur Gefahr wird mit dem Prozess gegen
den Mörder wird es vor allem für
Marianne immer und erträglicher nicht
mal ein Jahr vergeht bis zum ersten
Prozess Tag und bis dahin geht die
Mutter durch die absolute Hölle wie wir
wissen hat sie ihre ersten beiden Kinder
zur Adoption freigegeben die jüngste
Tochter die sie bei sich behalten hat
und bei dir sie vielleicht jetzt alles
richtig machen möchte hat sie nun auf
die grausamste Art und Weise verloren
nach dem Mord gibt sie anders Körper zur
Obduktion frei später wird Marianne von
einem Psychiater gefragt ob sie den
Mörder ihrer Tochter umgebracht hat weil
sie selbst Schuldgefühle hätte das
verneint sie und schreibt einen wütenden
Brief an den Arzt in ihr Tagebuch wenn
es ein Schuldgefühl gegeben hat dann
dass sie den leblosen Körper ihrer
Tochter nicht vor der Obduktion bewahrt
hat
in einem Interview liest Marianne aus
ihrem Tagebuch vor ich zitiere
ich hätte hingehen müssen in dieses
gruselige Institut hätte die schwingtüre
aufstoßen müssen geradewegs auf den
Aluminiumtisch zustürzen müssen auf dem
sie ja eben die Augen mit Pinzetten
aufreißen die für immer geschlossenen
Augen um aufschreiben zu können dass sie
blau waren mein Gott wem nutzt das zu
wissen dass sie blau waren außer mir
welcher Wahrheitsfindung wird hier
gedient ich hätte sie vom Tisch nehmen
müssen ihren folterinnen reißen und sie
die mitgebrachte Decke Hüllen denn sie
liegt dort nackt und dann mit dir
zusammen aus der Schwingtür hinausgehen
müssen ich hätte mit dir sprechen müssen
hier sagen müssen wie die Welt ohne sie
aussieht
dass sie immer noch ein Aussehen hat
diese Welt auch ohne sie wenn auch ganz
anders ich hätte sie fest an mich
drücken müssen um ihr die Angst zu
nehmen vor dem was auf sie zukommt die
Ewigkeit
stattdessen ließ sich sie zerschnibbeln
nennen sie es ruhig Schuldgefühle Herr
Doktor es ist viel mehr es ist eine
nicht wiedergut zu machende Schuld es
zerreißt mir wirklich das Herz na das
muss man sich einmal vorstellen dein
eigenes Kind wird ermordet vielleicht
sogar sexuell missbraucht und nach der
Tat kannst du erstmal kein Grab besuchen
und hast das Gefühl dass dein Kind keine
Ruhe finden kann du selbst willst
vielleicht auch einfach nur trauern aber
stattdessen wird alles im wahrsten Sinne
des Wortes zerstückelt und auseinander
genommen und dann endlich der Prozess
jetzt soll der Täter für seine Straftat
bestraft werden aber auch hier geht es
weiter und zwar auf Kosten der Toten
Tochter Klaus Grabowski steht im März
1981 vom Landgericht Lübeck eine Aussage
seinerseits steht im Raum
anstatt frei herauszugeben dass er die
kleine Anna entführt womöglich
missbraucht und ermordet hat kommt er
zunächst mit einer Geschichte um die
Ecke die unglaublich ist
er behauptet das Mädchen sei aus freien
Stücken zu ihm gekommen um ihn zu
erpressen eine Mark wollte sie von ihm
haben ansonsten würde sie rumgehen und
erzählen er habe sie angefasst aus Angst
diesmal unschuldig in einer Anstalt zu
kommen habe er sie erwürgt diese Aussage
lässt die Eltern der kleinen fassungslos
auf ihren Stühlen im Verhandlungssaal
zurück
kurz vor dem dritten Verhandlungstag
soll Marianne Bachmeier auf dem Flur
gehört haben dass Klaus Grabowski erneut
eine Aussage machen möchte außerdem ist
der Gerichtsmediziner Otto privilea
geladen er soll den Obduktionsbericht
abgeben aber so weit soll es nicht
kommen
Marianne will auf keinen Fall das über
ihre Tochter noch einmal Lügen
verbreitet werden sie beschließt zu
handeln
Werbung du liebst Podcasts und möchtest
deine Lieblingshose auf großer Bühne
live erleben dann habe ich einen
besonderen Veranstaltungstipp für dich
dass hier and now Podcast Festival von
Seven one Audio am zweiten und dritten
september in Köln mit dabei sind
beliebte Podcast wie beste Freundinnen
Hazel und Thomas Hörerlebnis Mord auf Ex
AWF Nr Psychologie to go 50 + 2 und
viele viele mehr es gibt Einzeltickets
mit denen du deinen lieblingspodcast
sehen kannst und Kombi und Festival
Tickets um dir mehrere Chance an
zugucken und dir dein ganz eigenes
Festival-Programm zusammen zu stellen
denn es gibt an zwei Tagen mehr als 20
live Podcast auf vier Bühnen in der
Halle Tor 2 in Köln und draußen davor
noch eine außen area mit food Trucks mit
Getränken mit Musik also echtes Festival
Feeling alle Infos zu dem Event und auch
zu den Tickets findest du auf vier and
now festival.de
Werbung Ende
und so wird der Gerichtsmediziner
pribilla an diesem Tag keinen Bericht
abgeben erst lediglich vor Ort um den
Tod des Angeklagten festzustellen alles
geht verdammt schnell es ist kurz nach
10 Uhr am Vormittag gerade haben zwei
Wachtmeister Klaus Grabowski aus der
Untersuchungshaft in den Saal des
Gerichts gebracht der Angeklagte setzt
sich auf seinen Stuhl mit Blick nach
vorn auf den noch leeren Richtertisch
seinen Rücken wendet er dem
Zuschauerraum zu er sieht seine Mörderin
nicht kommen
die dunkelhaarige junge Frau schicke
kleidet im schwarzen Tuchmantel tritt
hervor sie zieht eine Pistole eine
baretta 70 aus ihrer Tasche sie zielt
und schießt 8 Schüsse fallen sechs der
Geschosse mit Kaliber 5,6 mm treffen
Klaus Grabowski in den Rücken der Mann
ist sofort tot Marianne Bachmeier wird
festgenommen und wird über Nacht zur
Berühmtheit
Mitleid mit ihrem Opfer hat wohl keiner
ganz im Gegenteil zunächst wird Marianne
von vielen als Helden gefeiert die
Medien stürzen sich auf die Geschichte
ganz Deutschland schaut zu wird sie als
Mörderin verurteilt es ist wohl eine
Kombination aus dem Mitgefühl für die
Mutter da Wut auf den Täter aber auch
die Attraktivität von Marianne Bachmeier
die im Gesamtbild der Grund sind warum
die meisten Menschen Sympathie für sie
empfinden
Marianne macht sich verdammt gut auf den
Titelbildern der Zeitung eine schlanke
junge Frau mit glatten mittellang
dunkelbraunen Haaren für aussehen kann
sie natürlich nicht aber es ist so
leicht damit so einer gut aussehenden
und natürlich wirken den jungen Frauen
zu fühlen als mit einer möglicherweise
unausgeschlafene optisch
heruntergekommenen Kneipen wird
sie verkauft die Rechte an ihrer
Lebensgeschichte für rund 250.000 Mark
an den Sternen jetzt geht es nicht mehr
nur um die trauernde Mutter sondern um
den Menschen
Marianne Bachmeier je bekannter Marianne
Wirtz und je mehr die Menschen über sie
erfahren desto weiter gehen die
Meinungen zu ihr auseinander das Bild
der perfekten Mutter die um ihr Kind
trauert wird unter anderem geschmälert
als herauskommt dass sie bereits zwei
Kinder hat zudem behauptet Marianne aus
dem Affekt herausgeschossen zu haben es
sei eine Kurzschlusshandlung gewesen wer
aber bringt eine geladene Waffe mit in
einen Gerichtssaal ohne die Absicht zu
haben diese zu benutzen
wie kann es sein dass eine ungeübte
Schützin so ruhig bleibt und so
treffsicher ist
die beste Freundin von Marianne
Bachmeier sagt später das Marianne vor
dem Prozessbeginn sehr wohl
Schießübungen gemacht hat heimlich im
Keller unter ihrer lauten Kneipe damit
die Nachbar nichts mitkriegen zehn
Monate sind zwischen dem Tod von Anna
Bachmeier und der Verhandlung gegen
Grabowski vergangen zehn Monate in denen
Marianne Bachmeier durch die Hölle
gegangen sein muss lange genug damit
sich Trauer in Hass verwandeln und ein
Racheplan geschmiedet werden kann
im November 1982 beginnt der Prozess
gegen Marianne die Anklage lautet
zunächst auf Mord am Ende verurteilt sie
das Landgericht im März 1983 allerdings
wegen Totschlags und unerlaubten
Waffenbesitzes zu sechs Jahren Haft
schon zwei Jahre später kommt sie frei
ihre Reststrafe wird zu Bewährung
ausgesetzt
mittlerweile ist Marianne nicht mehr mit
dem Vater von Anna zusammen sondern
heiratet noch im Jahr ihrer Entlassung
einen Lehrer und sieht aus Deutschland
weg nichts hält sie mir in dem Land in
dem sie so viel gelitten und verloren
hat erst geht sie nach Nigeria später
nach ihrer Scheidung 1990 nach Sizilien
hier fliegt sie sterben dann in einem
Hospiz und schreibt dann ihre
Autobiografie
auch wenn der Wirbel um sie nachgelassen
hat gibt sie bis Mitte der 90er Jahre
immer wieder Interviews und tritt im
Fernsehen auf im September 1995 ist
Marianne Bachmeier in der Talkshow
fliege im Ersten zu Gast hier gesteht
sie dass Sie Klaus Grabowski keineswegs
immer perfekt sondern nach reiflicher
Überlegung erschossen habe sie wollte es
nicht zulassen dass dieser weiter
Unwahrheiten über einer verbreitet und
hat es als ihre Pflicht angesehen Recht
über ihn zu sprechen
ich denke und hoffe Mariana hat mit den
Jahren ihren Frieden gefunden und egal
was man von ihr halten mag ein gewisses
Grundverständnis und Mitgefühl wird wo
jeder mit dieser Frau haben ihr Leben
ist gezeichnet von viel Gewalt Ablehnung
Verlust und einer zur Schaustellung in
der Öffentlichkeit sowohl von der
positiven als auch von der negativen
Seite nur ein Jahr nach dem TV-Auftritt
bei Fliege stirbt Marianne Bachmeier im
Alter von 46 Jahren an
Bauchspeicheldrüsenkrebs
mit der Krebsdiagnose ist sie zurück in
ihre alte Heimat gezogen und ist in
einem Lübecker Krankenhaus gestorben
Marina Bachmeier ist neben dem Grab
ihrer Tochter beigesetzt worden
was für eine Frau egal ob man nur mit
dir sympathisiert oder sie für
berechnend und scharf auf den ganzen
Medien Rummel gehalten hat der Fall
Marianne Bachmeier hat Justiz Geschichte
geschrieben ich bin selbst Vater einer
mittlerweile erwachsenen Tochter und ich
mache mir gar nicht vorstellen wie ich
in einer solchen Situation gehandelt
hätte aber bei allem Verständnis für die
Trauer und Wut man darf so ein Verhalten
natürlich nicht rechtfertigen und
legitimieren denn für solche Fälle gibt
es Gesetze und Selbstjustiz kann nun mal
nicht der richtige Weg sein sonst würden
wir in einer Anarchie Leben in der jeder
selbst bestimmen kann was richtig und
falsch ist
aber Natalie wie siehst du diesen Fall
was beschäftigt dich dabei hast du
Verständnis für die Frau oder ist sie
für dich meine Kriminelle
ich finde es total schwierig weil
normalerweise würde ich dir auch total
zustimmen und sagen selbst Justiz ist
keine Lösung und ich würde auch niemals
dazu raten das gut heißen oder
irgendetwas in dieser Richtung aber in
diesem Fall ist Marianne Bachmeier aus
emotionaler Sicht für mich keine
kriminelle sondern einfach nur eine
Mutter ja diese Bestie hat die Kind
total aus dem Leben gerissen und besitzt
dann noch die Frechheit derartig über
ihre Tochter zu reden also das macht
mich ja jetzt hier von außen so viele
Jahre später noch unglaublich wütend ich
kann mir ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
vorstellen wie viel Wut und auch
Hilflosigkeit das in der Mutter
hervorgerufen haben muss so oder so ist
es fast schade dass ich dieser Klaus
Grabowski nicht seiner Tat stellen
musste wir werden also nie erfahren was
wirklich an diesem fünften mai 1980
passiert ist das Wissen hat er mit ins
Grab genommen
sicher ist auf jeden Fall dass man aus
dem Fall gelernt hat denn heute sind die
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen deutlich höher
heute könnte Marianne Bachmeier nicht
einfach so mit einer geladenen Waffe in
den Saal gehen und einen ungeschützten
Angeklagten erschießen bei allem Hass
bei aller Wut und bei aller Trauer
selbstjustiz ist und bleibt eine
Straftat auch wenn man die Gefühle der
Mutter nachvollziehen kann das war's für
heute wir danken euch fürs zuhören und
freuen uns wenn ihr auch bei der
nächsten Folge wieder dabei seid bei
Tatort Deutschland Spezial euer Mirko
und eure Natalie den spannenden Fall von
Selbstjustiz in Deutschland haben wir
mit dem Archiv der Bild-Zeitung erzählt
so wie Auszügen aus Artikeln der Welt
der Hamburger Morgenpost und in
Deutschland Funk Kalenderblatt außerdem
haben wir uns die spiegelreportage der
Fall Marianne Bachmeier angesehen die
Reportage Marianne Bachmeier selbst
Justiz im Gerichtssaal und das
gesellschaftscrimeformat von Funk der
Fall Redaktion
Stefan Netzeband und Antonia Heiler
Produktion serdarinis
soweit der Fall Marianne Bachmeier ja
jetzt geht es in der Zeit knapp 20 Jahre
zurück es geht um zwei Leichen und die
Rolle der Politik in einem der
mysteriösesten Morde der deutschen
Nachkriegsgeschichte
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
da sind wir wieder mit einem spannenden
Fall ich bin Mirko Kasimir und ich freue
mich dass ich heute Natalie Strauß an
meiner Seite habe Mirko das Boot
natürlich auf Gegenseitigkeit und heute
haben wir eine Geschichte die hat von
allem zu viel eine schöne Frau Reichtum
Sex Lügen Schüsse Aufregung Justiz
Irrtümer und vielleicht sogar
Geheimdienst Schmutz und eine
Waffenhandel connection ja das klingt
nach einem spannenden Krimi würde ich
sagen der Fall wurde übrigens benannt
nach der angeblichen Täterin und die
heißt Vera grüner bevor wir mehr über
sie erfahren schauen wir uns die gute
erst mal an Vera grünes sieht in den
1960er Jahren aus wie eine
Ü 50 Traumfrau vieler deutscher sie
trägt ihr Stroh blondes gelocktes Haar
meist offen es schlank und sportlich sie
hat große wache Augen eine wohlgeformte
Nase und einen vollen Mund wäre Brünen
er kann mitreißen humorvoll gucken aber
auch dramatisch Ernst jetzt aber Schluss
mit den Äußerlichkeiten
[Musik]
Vera wird am 6 februar 1910 als Vera
Maria Kohlen in Essen geboren ihr Vater
Ludwig Kohlen ist Bürgermeister des
Ortes von kraileite der später ein
Stadtteil von Essen wird ihre beiden
Brüder studieren Jura wäre dagegen darf
nur eine Haushaltsschule besuchen boah
wow die gute alte Zeit ja leider die
schlechte nicht gerade frauenfreundliche
Zeit geprägt von verstaubten
Rollenbildern na ja zurück zum Fall
Vera Kohlen heiratet 1937 den
Schauspieler Hans cosy bürgerlich lautet
der Nachname übrigens korsiolkowski den
müssen wir uns für später merken
1941 kommt Tochter Silvia zur Welt und
1943 sorgte Krieg für eine erste
dramatische Wendung in Veras Leben ihr
Mann hat den Handwerker Johann fehrbach
auf das Grundstück der Familie bestellt
weil dort ein Luftschutzbunker gebaut
werden soll bei einem Bombenangriff wird
zerstört fehrbach rettet Vera und ihre
Tochter und nimmt sie bei sich zu Hause
auf schon in dieser Zeit leben Vera und
fehrbach offenbar für eine Weile in
einer Art Beziehung aber ihre Ehe mit
Cossy alias kosynkowski wird erst 1953
geschieden Vera zieht in der
Zwischenzeit nach München hält aber
Kontakt zu verbach sie heiratet den
Handwerker aber nicht sondern den
Filmkomponisten Lothar Brünner ich kann
mir das ein Stück weit vorstellen ich
meine wenn du nur zur Haushaltsschule
gehen darfst dann achtest du natürlich
darauf dir einen wohlhabenden Mann zu
angeln der grüne ist übrigens auch nur
ein Jahr nach der Scheidung von Vera mit
58 Jahren gestorben im Jahr ihre
Scheidung kommt es für Vera grüne zu
einer schicksalhaften Begegnung sie
besitzt mehrere Eigentumswohnungen in
einer davon in München Schwabing wohnt
sie selbst schließlich kommt sie aus
einer gutbürgerlichen Familie und
verfügt über die gerichtlich getrennten
Mittel aus zwei Scheidungen aber
trotzdem muss regelmäßig Geld in die
Kasse im spießigen Vokabular der 50er
und 60er sagt man wohl sie bietet sich
wohlhabenden Herren als Begleitung an
dass das gut funktioniert zeigt die
schicksalhafte Begegnung die Mirko
angekündigt hat im Sommer 1957 kommt sie
in einer Gaststätte mit dem geschiedenen
Gynäkologen dr Otto Braun ins Gespräch
der Mann ist 16 Jahre älter als sie
begleitet wird er an diesem Abend von
Elfriede Klo sie ist 46 Jahre alt und
führt seinen Haushalt und nach allem was
später ermittelt wird ist sie auch seine
Partnerin schon hier fängt es mit den
etwas sehr schrägen menschlichen
Beziehung an denn Elfriede klug verlässt
das Lokal während Frauen und wäre sich
prächtig unterhalten da entsteht eine
Arzt Dreieck oder sogar Viereck wir
versuchen das jetzt mal so ein bisschen
auseinander zu tröseln Frauen überlässt
Vera grüne einen gebrauchten VW Käfer
und er bittet sie ihm an zwei Abenden in
der Woche zur Verfügung zu stehen
angeblich nur als Fahrerin dafür bekommt
Vera 200 Marke Monat man muss dazu sagen
dass dieser Doktor braun für damalige
Verhältnisse stinkreich sein muss der
Mann betreibt eine kassenarztpraxis in
München und hat eine Villa in Pöcking am
Starnberger See außerdem gehören Ihnen
zwei Mietshäuser in München und eine
Finca in Spanien läuft bei ihm und wie
du schon richtig sagtest dass
Beziehungsgeflecht ist sehr spannend
denn auch mit der Verwalterin dieses
spanischen Besitzes in Lloret de Mar hat
braun offenbar eine Beziehung laufen die
Frau heißt Katja Hinze und braun hat sie
als Erben der Finca in seinem Testament
festgelegt wie sie später zeigt besitzt
Frauen auch Schusswaffen er soll nie
ohne aus dem Haus gegangen sein man
könnte übrigens einen eigenen Podcast
über diesen Ort machen er kam aus einer
Familie von Geheimdienstlern der
Nazizeit Frauen selbst arbeitete in der
NS-Diktatur als Arzt für die Allianz
Versicherung
da soll er ein Ehepaar mit gefälschten
Attesten vor der Zwangsarbeit gerettet
haben da gibt es sogar noch ein
spannendes Nebengleis Frauen war mit der
früheren Geheimagentin Sonja
blättschacher befreundet sie wurde 1954
tot mit einer Schusswunde aufgefunden
die Polizei legte den Todesfall aber
später als Suizid zu den Akten wie
bereits am Anfang angekündigt in dieser
Geschichte gibt es von allem zu viel vor
allem zu viele enge Beziehungen und das
bedeutet eine Menge Streitpotenzial Ende
der 50er Jahre hält Otto Braun offenbar
immer größere Stücke auf die schöne Vera
Brüne im Oktober 57 fährt er mit ihr zur
Finca in Lloret de Mar und im Jahr
darauf feiert ihr Katja hinter als
Verwalterin und streicht sie aus dem
Testament neue Erben Vera grüne das
ganze beziehungsweise Durcheinander in
zwei die Familie Braun Weihnachten 1959
zerstreiten sich Otto Braun und seinen
damals 29-jähriger Sohn Günther der in
München ebenfalls als Arzt arbeitet von
ihm werden wir noch hören wir sind jetzt
im Jahr 1960 braun entschließt sich die
Finca in Spanien zu verkaufen aber dazu
kommt es erst gar nicht Anfang 1960
zeigt sich auch in Vera grünes Leben
spielt immer noch Johann Ferbach eine
Rolle wir erinnern uns das ist ihr
Retter aus dem Krieg die beiden sind
Ende Februar zusammen beim Karneval in
Köln Natalie bevor wir zum April 1960
kommen lassen wir das Gemälde noch mal
auf uns wirken wir haben den Reichen
Arzt Dr braun der ist kürzlich seine
Geliebte und Erben Katja Hinze in die
Wüste geschickt hat er hat aber noch
eine enge Beziehung zu seiner
Haushälterin Elfriede und zu seiner
angeblichen Chauffeurin Vera die
wiederum immer noch Kontakt zu ihrem
langjährigen Gefährten Johann Held nicht
vergessen sollten wir in dieser
Aufzählung die Kinder wäre es Tochter
silviakowski ist gerade 19 Jahre alt und
macht sich in München als Namen Brauns
Sohn Günther arbeitet als Assistenzarzt
in der Stadt und hat sich gerade erst
mit dem Vater überworfen im April 1960
ist Vera viel unterwegs unter anderem
besucht sie vom 8 bis 13.4 ihre Mutter
in Bonn die ist ebenso krank wie damals
gerade ihr dauerbekannter Johann
fehrbach den sie am 13 April in Köln
besucht all diese Daten werden später
aus guten Grund festgehalten auch das
Vera grüne am 14 April aus NRW nach
München zurückkehrt und dort ein Auto
abholt das Braun für Sie geordert hat
mit April stimmt etwas nicht rund um die
Braunsche Villa in Pöcking das fällt dem
Arbeiter Uli Schauer auf der sich um den
Garten kümmert und ist alarmiert Brauns
Sprechstundenhilfe Renate Meier und
ihren Freund Hans-joachim Vogel weil sie
braun nicht ans Telefon kriegen fahren
Sie nach Starnberg Renate Meier und
Hans-joachim Vogel melden sich am 19
April
1960 spät abends um 23:45 Uhr bei der
Polizei in Feldafing weil bei ihrem
Kontrollbesuch in Pöcking jemand
aufgemacht hat zwei Streifenbeamte
fahren zur Villa und öffnen Sie sofort
stoßen sie auf die Leiche von Braun der
mit einer Schusswunde an der Schläfe an
der Heizung in der Diele liegt ein
Inspektor der später dazu stößt findet
im Keller schließlich auch die Leiche
von Elfriede Clou auch sie weiß eine
eintrittswunde auf und zwar am Genick
wenige Tage später sind Justiz und
Gerichtsmedizin bereit den Fall zu den
Akten zu legen offenbar hat Dr braun
erst Elfriede erschossen und dann sich
selbst nennt man erweiterter Suizid im
Amts Deutsch der Fall und beide Toten
werden begraben aber beide werden
wiederkommen den Sohn Günther braun will
die Geschichte vom Selbstmord nicht
wahrhaben erst recht nicht als wäre das
Haus in Lloret de Mar erben soll Günther
erwirkt bei der Staatsanwaltschaft die
Wiederaufnahme der Ermittlungen und die
Exhumierung der Leichen bei der
Orthopädie der Leiche von Frauen stellt
sich heraus er hat zwei Schusswunden am
Kopf kann sich also gar nicht selbst
getötet haben und so werden Vera grüne
und Johann Ferbach im Oktober 1961
verhaftet 25 April 1962 vor dem
Landgericht München 2 beginnt der
Prozess wegen der vielen Schaulustigen
und Fotografen bricht in der Umgebung
der Verkehr zusammen den Vorsitz hat ein
Doktor Klaus Seibert insgesamt werden
drei Berufsrichter und sechs leihen über
den fallurteilen und schon vor der
ersten Anhörung sieht es nicht gut aus
für Vera grüner da ist dieser unfassbare
Klopper mit ihrer Tochter Silvia die war
zum Tatzeitpunkt in England sie
behauptet aber noch vor Prozessbeginn
gegenüber Reportern und der Polizei das
Vera ihr gegenüber dem Mord gestanden
hat genauer gesagt dass Sie Johann
fehrbach dazu gebracht habe Otto Braun
und Elfriede Klo zu erschießen fehrbach
wiederum wird von einem Häftling namens
Siegfried Schramm belastet mit dem er in
u saß Schramm sagt fehrbach habe ihm
gegenüber mit dem Mord in Pöcking
geprahlt im Prozess nimmt immerhin
verast Tochter Silvia ihre Aussage
zurück aber schwerwiegen die Geschichten
die Browns Sohn Günther und
sprechstundenhilferin Nathe Meyer
beisteuern die beteuert verbach habe
sich am Tag Zutritt zur Villa verschafft
weil er sich als Kaufinteressent für die
Finke in Spanien ausgab diese Version
soll auch ein getippter briefstützen den
Sohn Günther als Beweisstück präsentiert
das Schreiben war angeblich von Braun an
Elfriede gerichtet und kündigte den
Besuch eines Herrn Dr Schmitz an das
muss man vielleicht so erklären laut
Sohn Günther wollte Vera grüne ihrem
Freund Johann Zugang zu Frauen
verschaffen deshalb kündigte sie ihn als
Kaufinteressenten dr Schmitz an der nach
Pöcking kommen würde das Gericht hält am
Ende folgendes für die Wahrheit
Vera grüne und Johann fehrbach
verschafften sich am 14 April 1960 mit
der Geschichte vom geplanten Hauskauf
Zugang zur Villa in und erschießen Otto
Braun und Elfriede Clou
Todeszeitpunkt Brauns sei folglich der
gleiche Tag um 19:45 Uhr gewesen die
Angeklagten werden am 4 juni 1962 wegen
gemeinschaftlichen Doppelmordes zu
lebenslanger Haft verurteilt ein
Fehlurteil zumindest ein Urteil das
heute niemand mehr so in Deutschland
Fällen würde da waren sich Jahre später
eigentlich alle einig dafür gibt es auch
viele gute Gründe und der stärkste ist
der Todeszeitpunkt die Gerichtsmedizin
und das Gericht legen sich auf den Abend
des 14 aprilfest spätere Überprüfung
ergaben aber den 20 April da war Vera
grüner aber gar nicht im Raum München
sondern von Zeugen bestätigt in Bonn
auch der angeblich bei den Toten
gefundene Brief der auf blaues Papier
getippt war darf als zweifelhaft gelten
das Schreiben hatten keinesfalls
Polizisten am Tatort gefunden sondern
Sohn Günther überreichte es dem Gericht
ja das ist übrigens der gleiche Günther
der an Vera Stelle die Finca in Lloret
de Mar erbte der Fall wäre Brüne hat
also Rechtsgeschichte geschrieben weil
er so schlampig verhandelt wurde aber
neu aufgenommen wurde er trotz allem
nicht viel mehr wurde Vera Brüne nach 18
Jahren Haft im Jahr 1979 vom bayerischen
Ministerpräsidenten Strauß begnadigt sie
zog danach in ihre alte Wohnung zurück
sie starb 2001 im Krankenhaus immerhin
im Alter von 91 Jahren aber Mirko wenn
wir mal annehmen dass sie unschuldig war
wer war es dann
ja natürlich weil Frauen so eine
schillernde Figur war gibt es da so
einige Theorien zum Beispiel soll er in
illegalen Waffenhandel verwickelt
gewesen sein und machte sich so
vielleicht Feinde Frauen wurde z.B mit
einem Bestechungsskandalen Verbindung
gebracht bei dem es um Schützenpanzer
ging und einer der Akteure dabei war ein
gewisser Werner reppening und rate mal
wessen persönlicher Referent der war
keine Ahnung ja er war die rechte Hand
von Franz Josef Strauß also dem
Ministerpräsidenten der Vera grüne
begnadigt hat puh also hatte der
vielleicht ein schlechtes Gewissen kann
es sein ja wer weiß das schon alle die
was dazu sagen könnten sind längst tot
[Musik]
das ist echt ein krasser Fall mit vielen
Zutaten zu viel um ehrlich zu sein wir
haben ihn erzählt mit den Einträgen aus
dem Fall Archiv des Axel Springer
Verlages sowie mit älteren Artikeln der
Abendzeitung und des Münchner Merkurs
gute Orientierung bietet auch die
Chronik die der online-ritzinsen sind
die da wunderlich zusammengestellt hat
Link dazu gibt es natürlich in den Show
Notes Aufnahme und Script Stefan
netzwandt Schnitt Antonia Heier
Postproduktion durch die weight world
Studios München bis bald euer Mirko
vielen Dank dass ihr dabei wart euren
Natalie
und dieses Mal haben wir ganz am Ende
auch noch eine Einzelheit sozusagen als
Hidden Track ein unfassbares Detail
Mirko am Morgen nach dem Leichen von den
Pöcking war der Dackel von Otto Braun
gefunden worden
jemand wahrscheinlich der oder die
Mörder hatten ihn in einem Kellerraum
weggesperrt und der Kommissar der am
nächsten Morgen eintraf der erschoss den
armen Hund und ließ ihn auf dem Gelände
begraben
das ist unfassbar ja ich würde sagen der
ganze Fall ist unfassbar Alter
der Hund noch irgendwelche Beweisstücke
gehabt
schreiben
[Musik]
so weit unser sommer-spezial für heute
für nächste Woche haben wir Euch zwei
äußerst knifflige cold cases vorbereitet